hello everyone and welcome to another
excellent game from round 1.2 of the
2019 3d World Cup I think this is the
most requested game from those of you
who used hashtag suggestion
Jorge quarry proven grandmaster against
the initial sorry in Indian Grand Master
who is also the youngest participant of
the 2019 World Cup and in their round
1.1 nickel one with the white pieces so
here quarry really needs a win if he
wants to take this matchup in two
tiebreaks which are the the rapid game
send if in the rapid games are tied then
you go into blitz and so on I don't know
if there's an Armageddon I haven't
checked or or how the matchup is decided
but regarding ratings quarry is some 50
points higher rated than Nico Nico is I
think around 26 10 and Jorge's 2660 so
Cory definitely the favorite but now
he's in a tough position he has to
equalize otherwise he gets knocked out
of the competition and grabs his $6,000
but he has the white pieces so let's see
what happens
we have c-4 by Corey and II 6 by siren
the Asian core defense if I've
pronounced that correctly Knight to f3
with d5 and III of the English of course
Knight to f6 Knight the c3 developing
both nights and b6 now Anejo is already
too pink out of his light square Bishop
with b3 Bishop to b7 and Bishop to b2
now Corey is following the game Nihal
already played with the black pieces
against Alexa Trev in the 2018 blitz
championship in sankt-petersburg which
ended in a draw night BB 7 with Bishop
to e2 preparing to castle and now a6
with castles by Corey Bishop to d6
anyhow also now ready to castle and d4
with castles and here we reach a point
where the game takes a different turn
here Queen to c2 this is what Alex say
they have played against Nihal in the
world the Blitz championship last year
but here we have a 4 and a 4 is also a
new move in the position so it's already
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game we've see 5 by Annie Hall you
want you don't want your backwards pawn
here to stay there forever so c5
attacking the center with h3 and the now
rook to e8 rook to e1 both players just
putting the rooks and useful squares h6
and now push it back to f1 we've worked
the c8 bringing the other hook into the
game as well and curry does the same
with rook the c1 and now Queen to e7
connecting rooks and now rook the c2 as
Corey is expecting D captures on c4 he
wants the well bring the Queen eater to
d3 or e2 and then bring this rook over
to be 1s he's expecting the B file to be
opened and Nico still has the b6
backwards pawn so perhaps that pawn can
become a target with rook b8 and now
Queen to e 2 preparing rook to B 1 D
captures on c4 sorry D captors on c4 b
cat person c4 as planned and now Knight
to f8 this Knight is now coming to g6
and look the b1 now Cory wants to play
Bishop to c1 bring this rook over here
and try well try to gobble up some
points on the Queen side Knights to g6
and now Bishop to see one now the B six
ponies under attack so Nihal has to
defend it with Queen to be Quinta c7
defending and now rook c2 b2 so the b6
pawn is under attack and there is not an
easy way to defend the pawn nickel found
a very interesting way how to defend the
pawn he played C capture Sun b4e cap for
Sundy for and now you can to just defend
it with Knight to d7 or something like
that you get c5 and it's not not another
pleasant move to face you can have
capture otherwise you get row capture
some b7 but Nico founded a very
interesting Bishop to a three and now if
you go after the pawn for example rook
captures and b6
you get the unfortunate Bishop captures
on f3 Queen captures and Bishop
characters and c1 you lose a piece you
cannot recapture
you recaptured than just Queen captures
rook on d6 so after a three Corey has to
get rid of his rooks from the B file we
have rook the sorry not to the c2 we
have rook to D - sorry that's D - Bishop
captures on c1 rook captures on c1 and
now Nihal with this bishop a3 with
captors and c1 maneuver was able to get
rid of both of the rooks from the B file
and now Queen to f4 just a really active
move putting a lot of pressure on white
position and he had already won Game one
so he just needs a draw in this game to
advance in defeated World Cup putting
pressure on the rook and see one you'd
have to be careful what you do with this
rook also just the threat is capture and
f3 you know minimize material on the
board you know
allow yourself and easily drawn position
and then if your opponent decides to
push maybe you can grab even more Queen
- III offering a Queen trade and here at
nihill just grabs the night s plan
Bishop captures on f3 g captures if
Queen captures an f4 first like I said
after this trade you don't really
why doesn't really have anything to go
on here the pawn structure is a room and
he has four point Islands black has two
pylons and well not not much to go on
and the white needs a win in this game
so G captures on f3 and now nihill just
avoids a queen trade as he doesn't want
to allow white this excellent point
Center Queen to h4 so what do you play
here it's a really tough position and
white is really struggling here what
best you can hope for if this was like a
normal classical game if Jorge did not
have to go for a win probably f4 and
after you clear the g3 square for your
queen play something like this you give
you have to give up a pawn and after
this straight here Knight goes back and
you play the same game being up upon and
hope for a draw but white cannot afford
a draw so white played look to be won he
wants to grab the b6 pawn and try to
create some chances you know some
imbalances in the game but this does not
work Annie Hall now has a wonderful
winning idea
I feel free to pause it and find this
wonderful winning idea while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you are an excellent
finder of winning ideas in the World Cup
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show
Knight to f4 seems pretty obvious as the
h3 pawn is under attack but you also
have to see that if King defends it with
King to h2 the King and Bishop now guard
eh3 pawn now you have to see rook
captures and c4 the bishop is well
overloaded he can't keep an eye on the
h3 point and the rook as well and here
without the C pawn you're just you're
just lost that was that was the only
thing you had to go for hoping for rook
captures and maybe start pushing the
pasty pawn but here there's no good way
to continue this of course if you
capture the rook you're getting
checkmated at that of course it doesn't
even need to be shown but I will show it
as it's a nice checkmate
so after Knight f4 we have rook captures
on b6 now hoping to start pushing the
pawn here and also now if you go for
check
Bishop captures Queen captures now c5
and you start pushing your past pawn
white can definitely gain some counter
play here so after real character stun
b6 Nina said no you don't look captures
on c4 and it's not just about
eliminating the point it also vacates
the d5 square for either of blacks
Knights which is a really powerful
square as you'll see in the game so here
there's not much to do black white as
the c-4 pony's now gone a wife to
decided to defend the Asian repond he
played King captures on h2 but now black
has several ways of ending this game so
feel free to pause the video and find
your favorite way of how to end the game
or you can try to find the best way to
end the game well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of any of the winning
ideas the winning ideas include this
Knight to d5 this Knight to d5 or the
straight forward rook captures on c3
rook captures and c3 was not played in
the game but doesn't really matter as
either of the three ideas is winning but
this is just seems to be the nicest one
as it immediately offers an exchange and
the idea is that after
Queen captures on c3 you play Knight d5
you attack the Queen and for the rook on
d6 and now there's really no no good way
to do this you can either try and defend
the rook or you can try anything let's
say you move the Queen Queen c2 or Queen
B - doesn't really matter you get Knight
captures on h3 and now there's nothing
to be done here
one special characters the other night
comes to f4 and you are once again
getting checkmated here so this was the
idea behind rope captures on c3 you're
not even interested in the rope here on
b6 on the other hand nights here or this
night here works just as fine nihill
played night six to d5 and then we just
had
well now the Queen and the rook or
forked a knight characters and after
Knight captures on d5 it was in this
position that [ __ ] jacorey brewing
Grand Master resigned the game and was
knocked out of the Vita World Cup
grabbed his $6,000 in the Nihal advances
in the second round where he faces L
star Safari of Azerbaijan and the game
is being played while I'm recording this
video and Denis hall has a very
promising position against the Farley so
we might see we might see more games
from the young Indian Grandmaster he
resigned here as whatever you play here
of course loses the idea maybe you can
give up the Queen for some material
let's say bushel captures on c4 Knight
captures and pawn captures and now okay
there are two rooks and a bishop against
the Queen and the rook but black will
have a very nice game and as White's
pieces are not really coordinating the
King is wide open let's say go Queen e1
you attack the rook rook blocks defends
the pawn
now you go Queen a5 and you're gonna
grab the a4 pawn start slowly winning
material bringing your rook into the
game of course if you capture the Queen
to c7 check will pick up the bishop so
one of the reasons why it's hard to play
your king is well really exposed on the
other hand after Knight captures on d5
you could try Queen to e4 just offering
your Queen trade but here black just
trades captures captures and the problem
is after Knight captures and b6 it also
defends the c4 rook so much of
characters Knight captures and black is
just up a piece and I always say
the best for last if Queen to b3 let's
say you don't go for a queen trade you
don't give up the Queen let's say we
just protect the rook what happens here
now
rook to see one wins the game this is
just wonderful you can't really do
anything here if you move the Queen
you're gonna lose the rook on d6 Knight
to f4 still still a threat and well of
course your Bishop on f1 is under attack
and the well the most beautiful thing of
all if you play Bishop to g2 the kinda
still keep an eye on the HT report then
just Queen to f4 is mate in one as now
the Recovery's the H file and well the
Queen just covers the dark scores so
this is a one of the nicer mates that
could have happened
our body after Knight captures on d5
Corey resigns and yeah another wonderful
victory for the youngest participant
over the Phaedo World Cup 2019 with two
straight wins which is incredible
against a higher rated opponent sure
that's the game a lot we have suggested
it so I do hope everyone enjoyed it I
would like to thank Oliver a robbery and
Martha Fernandez for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Phaedo
World Cup and of course checking up on
your suggestions while we figure out
where we're going with our next saga so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day